Hier im Männerhaus
war von Anfang an das Thema,
ob die Tochter hierherkommt
oder nicht.
Deshalb habe ich das Zimmer
mit dem Babybett bekommen.
Und ja, es schmerzt,
es jetzt leer anschauen zu müssen.
Aber man hofft
und ist eigentlich guter Dinge,
dass die Kleine bald da ist.
Wohin geht ein Mann,
der von seiner Frau physische und
psychische Prügel einstecken muss?
Und was macht er, wenn auch
noch ein Kind im Spiel ist?
Das Männer- und Väterhaus in Bern
ist ein letzter Zufluchtsort,
den auch Sebastian aufgesucht hat.
Die Männer und der Ort
müssen zum Schutz anonym bleiben.
Die Namen sind erfunden,
die Stimmen nachgesprochen.
Die Geschichten aber
könnten realer nicht sein.
Dies ist ein Film, der die üblichen
Geschlechterrollen ins Wanken bringt.
Das Männer- und Väterhaus
wird von einer Frau geleitet.
Sie erhält täglich Einblick
in den Abgrund
des nach wie vor
vorhandenen Geschlechtergrabens.
Es kommen v.a. Männer hierher, die
nicht verstanden und gesehen werden.
Sie werden nicht als Opfer gesehen,
sondern nur als Täter.
Sie werden nicht verstanden,
auch wenn sie Opfer sind.
Dass sie Bedürfnisse haben, die
ihnen auch gerecht werden müssen.
Sie werden nicht als Väter gesehen.
Sie werden nicht als Väter gesehen,
die gleichbehandelt
werden sollten wie Mütter.
Und man sollte ohne Vorurteile
auf sie zugehen.
Ich merke in unserer Gesellschaft,
dass jeder Mann
ein potenzieller Täter ist.
Ich finde, das ist nicht gerecht.
Es ist nicht gerecht.
Männer sind nicht potenzielle Täter.
Ihr Sinn für Gleichberechtigung
hat sie angestachelt.
Aufgewachsen als Angehörige einer
deutschen Minderheit in Rumänien,
hat sie Ausgrenzung
auch selber erfahren.
Ich bin jemand,
der gerne etwas Neues aufbaut
oder Pionierarbeit leistet.
Die Thematik
stand mir irgendwie nahe.
Ich hätte genauso etwas für Frauen,
Kinder oder was auch immer gemacht,
Es ging nicht speziell darum,
für Männer etwas zu machen.
Ich habe
eine Lücke im System bemerkt.
Da gibt es Leute, die durch
die Raster des Systems fallen,
das noch nicht abgedeckt ist.
Ob nach der Arbeit, zum Übernachten,
oder ganze Tage oder Wochen,
die Männer sind hier
in ihrer Not willkommen.
Als ausgebildete
systemische Beraterin
will Sieglinde Kliemen
das ganze System erkennen
und nicht nur Symptome behandeln.
Ich schreibe es jetzt dann auf.
Beat war hier schon mehrmals zu Gast.
Er kommt mittlerweile
lieber direkt ins Männerhaus,
als dass er noch einmal
zur Polizei geht.
Du hast das Gefühl,
nicht ernst genommen zu werden.
Ich habe es so erlebt. Ich hatte
das Gefühl, ausgelacht zu werden.
Gehst du zur Tür raus, schliesst
die Tür, sind da die beiden,
die mit dir das Interview
oder Protokoll gemacht haben,
und lachen über dich.
Ein Mann, der sich
von der Frau schlagen lässt!
Nach dem Motto: Das würde ich mir
nicht bieten lassen. Und, und, und.
Du bist in einem Clinch,
weil es ein Tabuthema ist.
Gehst du dorthin,
bist du ein Weichei.
Ganz einfach, ganz einfach.
Es ist sehr, sehr erniedrigend.
Ich würde auch gar nicht mehr gehen.
Ich könnte
halbtot geschlagen werden,
aber ich würde mir das
nicht mehr antun.
Ich hätte die Kraft
und den Mut nicht.
Beat fühlte sich von den Behörden
nicht ernst genommen.
Er, Opfer von Gewalt, musste sich
verteidigen und rechtfertigen.
Vor einem Jahr
hatte Beat einen Hirnschlag.
Seither schlage seine Frau
mit allen möglichen Gegenständen
immer wieder auf dieselbe Stelle.
Grosse Stimmungsschwankungen, für die
es kein anständiges Ventil gibt,
seien der Grund.
Die Gewalt nimmt kein Ende.
Eine Glasflasche, eine Weinflasche
auf dem Kopf zerschlagen,
solche Sachen.
Sie wollte mir gezielt
eine gröbere Behinderung zufügen.
Sie sagte auch:
"Ich bringe dich um!"
Sie drohte, mich umzubringen.
Dass sie einfach haargenau wisse,
wohin sie schlagen muss.
Und trotzdem trennt sich Beat nicht.
Da ist die Angst, bei einer Trennung
finanziell zugrunde zu gehen.
Dazu das Wissen
um die eigenen Unzulänglichkeiten,
dass er schneller
als Täter abgestempelt wird,
wenn er handgreiflich wird.
Nicht zuletzt
bindet ihn die Hoffnung,
dass es irgendwann
besser werden könnte.
Beat weiss zeitweise
weder aus noch ein.
Die Tür wieder verriegeln,
damit ja keiner reinkommt,
damit wir sicher sind.
Der Mann sieht sich selbst
nicht gerne als Opfer.
Das Opferbild des Mannes, auch bei
den Männern, die hierherkommen ...
Sie bezeichnen sich nicht gerne so.
Der Mann ist kein Opfer,
der Mann ist stark.
Dieses Männerbild
ist einfach vorhanden.
Wenn ein Mann
sich als Opfer bezeichnet,
bezeichnet er sich ja
automatisch als Versager.
Wer möchte sich schon
als Versager bezeichnen?
Und sie halten die Gewalt der Frauen
einfach aus.
Sie halten sie einfach aus.
Sie sagen, sie können das ertragen.
Was sie weniger ertragen können
und oft nicht sehen,
weil es sehr schleichend ist
und sie es nicht als Gewalt
bezeichnen würden,
ist die psychische Gewalt.
Die Kontrolle, die Beschimpfungen,
das Mobbing gegenüber den Kindern.
Die Eifersucht, die ...
Die nimmt manchmal Dimensionen an,
die man sich nicht vorstellen kann.
Und das alles, das ist ...
Das ist für sie
sehr, sehr schwierig.
Das ist sehr schwierig.
Der Stolz hat auch Sebastian lange
davon abgehalten, Hilfe zu holen.
Die körperlichen Verletzungen heilen,
auch wenn in seinem Fall das
Handgelenk noch operiert werden muss.
Aber der Schmerz, von der drei Monate
alten Tochter getrennt zu sein,
sitzt tief.
Nun ist er bei Sieglinde Kliemen
und kämpft darum,
seine Tochter
ins Väterhaus nehmen zu können.
Nachdem die Vaterschaft
mit einem Test geklärt werden musste,
kann er endlich
mit der KESB weiterschauen.
(Computerstimme) Sie werden
mit dem nächsten freien Mitarbeiter
verbunden.
* Piepton *
Er kann einen Vorfall schildern,
bei dem das Kindeswohl gefährdet war.
Die Kleine hat danach geschrien.
Ob es ihr wehtat oder ob sie
nur erschrak, kann ich nicht sagen.
Sie fragte mich,
ob sie die Kleine umbringen soll.
Ich antwortete, dann werde sie
in ihrem eigenen Leben
nie mehr zufrieden sein
und keine Freude mehr haben.
Dann hat sie mir -
auf gut Deutsch gesagt -
die Kleine in die Arme geworfen.
Wäre ich nicht bereit gewesen,
wäre sie auf den Boden gefallen.
Dann habe ich realisiert, dass sich
diese Frau nie ändern wird,
obwohl ich ihr
viele letzte Chancen gegeben habe.
Dazu noch zwei, drei
allerletzte Chancen.
Mit der Vorlage, dass sie
die Medikamente wieder einnimmt,
die Antidepressiva,
die sie lange abgesetzt
und nicht mehr eingenommen hat.
Ob und wie die Behörden handeln,
ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt noch offen.
Wenn ein Mann
quasi die bessere Mutter ist,
dann mag das manchmal
schwer zu verstehen sein.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Ja ...
Die KESB ist die richtige Stelle.
Ich denke jetzt, wir müssen
es einfach etwas aushalten.
Ich hoffe einfach,
dass ich meine Tochter
so schnell wie möglich wieder sehe.
Etwas fehlt
und man fühlt sich nicht vollkommen.
Man fragt sich 100-mal am Tag:
"Wo ist sie? Wie geht es ihr?"
"Wird auf sie aufgepasst?"
Was ich immer wieder feststelle,
ist ...
Ich drücke es wirklich ein bisschen
überspitzt und provokativ aus.
Ich stelle immer wieder
eine Mentalität fest,
die in der Gesellschaft herrscht,
auch im Helfersystem,
bei der man davon ausgeht,
dass die Mutter gut fürs Kind ist
und der Vater optional ist.
Das gilt v.a. da,
wo die Frauen oder Mütter
auch selbst sehr belastet sind
mit eigenen, persönlichen Problemen,
mit psychologischen Problemen.
Vielleicht auch mit Traumata,
die dazu geführt haben,
die entdeckt sind,
die behandelt werden
oder erst noch abgeklärt werden
müssen.
Da werden die Väter alleingelassen.
Die Alleingelassenen
suchen im Männer- und Väterhaus
oft einen letzten Hoffnungsschimmer.
Der nächste Gast auf Zeit
ist David mit seinen beiden Kindern.
Die Behörden hätten bei seiner
Situation nicht genau hingeschaut,
die Probleme der Frau kleingeredet,
bis er sich selber
zum Handeln gezwungen sah.
Ich habe kaum das Recht,
hier zu sein.
Wäre ich eine Frau
und würde weggehen,
könnte ich problemlos vier Monate
in einem Frauenhaus sein.
Aber ich: ein, zwei Wochen.
Ich habe kaum das Recht dazu.
Es ist, als würde ich
eine Kindsentführung machen.
* Verzerrte,
unverständliche Kinderstimme *
Wow!
* Verzerrte,
unverständliche Kinderstimme *
Geh runter, Schnuckelchen.
Bring es ihr rasch!
Die Türe schliessen!
Die Türe schliessen! Fest, fest!
Die einzige Lösung,
was sie immer sagten, war:
"Man muss gehen,
man muss sich scheiden lassen."
Wie kann ich als Vater gehen
und meine Kinder
in diesem Zustand zurücklassen?
Dann ist keiner mehr da.
Das ist es ja: Alle schauen weg.
Keiner schaut richtig hin.
Niemand schaut richtig hin.
Und die Kinder sind noch zu klein,
als dass sie die Situation
entsprechend einschätzen können.
Aber auch die Erwachsenen
sind in ihrem Kampf hilflos.
Es dreht sich immer wieder im Kreis.
Meist ist die Rede
von zwei Persönlichkeitsstörungen,
die sich nur schwer bis gar nicht
dingfest machen lassen,
Narzissmus und Borderline.
Gegen aussen ist es eine heile Welt,
alles schön und gut.
Aber sobald die Türen
geschlossen sind, fängt es an.
Dann fängt es an.
Das Geschrei, der Druck.
Es ist so, dass ich das
all die Jahre mitgemacht habe.
Ich habe es selbst miterlebt.
Ich war darin gefangen.
Was nachher war ...
Ich konnte es bei den Kindern
nicht mehr mitansehen.
Ich merkte,
dass ich nicht viel machen kann.
Anfangs habe ich eingegriffen,
wollte helfen.
Das machte alles schlimmer.
In letzter Zeit war es nur noch so,
dass ich wie ein Gast
daneben gestanden bin.
Ich habe zugeschaut und gewartet,
bis es vorbei war
und ich die Kinder beruhigen konnte.
Die Mutter sei überfordert,
hätte auch schon Therapie
in Anspruch genommen.
Und dann die ultimativen Druckmittel,
mit denen die Frau
dem Mann Angst einjagt:
Am Anfang war es so, sagte sie,
dass sie sich etwas antut ...
... dass sie sich etwas antut,
wenn wir auseinandergehen.
Mit den Kindern
war es natürlich der Klassiker:
"Ich nehme dir die Kinder weg.
Du siehst sie nie mehr."
Das war sehr stark vorhanden.
... wenn ich nicht mache, nicht
bleibe oder das nicht akzeptiere.
Dass wir auseinandergehen
und ich die Kinder nur noch
alle zwei Wochen für zwei Tage sehe.
Ist das die grösste Angst?
Das ist die grösste Angst überhaupt,
dass ich meine Kinder
nicht mehr sehe.
Es geht den Kindern
hier im Männer- und Väterhaus
den Umständen entsprechend gut.
* Ein Kind
singt mit verzerrter Stimme. *
Schön.
Sieglinde Kliemen ist auf Abruf da,
wenn man sie braucht.
Im Moment ist Zeichnen
mit den Kindern gefragt.
Du hast ein buntes Pferd.
Du machst es immer so schön bunt.
Es ist immer so schön bunt.
(Mit verzerrter Stimme)
Das ist megaschön.
Ja, deines aber auch.
Vermissen Sie sie,
wenn sie wieder gehen?
Nicht unbedingt.
Der nächste Fall kommt
und dann geht es weiter.
Natürlich
schliesst man sie ins Herz.
Aber vermissen
ist der falsche Ausdruck.
Es ist eine momentane Beziehung,
die wichtig ist,
die auch Stabilität geben soll
in dieser schwierigen Situation.
Dann ist wichtig, dass man wieder
loslassen kann, von beiden Seiten.
Ich bin keine Bezugsperson,
die in ihrem Leben bleiben wird.
Darauf muss man achten.
Zeit für Sentimentalität
bleibt nicht immer.
Ein anderer Gast ist verschwunden.
Beat, der von seiner Frau mit allem
Möglichen geschlagen wurde, ist weg.
Er ist einfach eines Tages
nicht mehr gekommen.
Ich habe das Zimmer jetzt geräumt.
Ich habe immer wieder versucht,
ihn zu erreichen,
aber er hat nicht geantwortet.
Es ist schwierig darüber zu grübeln,
warum er sich nicht meldet.
Er ist willkommen,
wenn er wieder Hilfe braucht.
Ich kann das Zimmer
nicht frei lassen,
weil es immer wieder Bedarf gibt.
Seine Sachen habe ich deponiert.
Machen Sie sich Sorgen?
Ja, Sorgen ... Wie soll ich sagen?
Man weiss nicht, wie es ihnen geht,
was die Motivation ist
und überhaupt.
Aber, ja ...
Wir nehmen es, wie es ist.
Ich kann die Situation nicht ändern.
Drei Monate nach diesen Dreharbeiten
erfahren wir,
dass Beat versucht hat,
sich das Leben zu nehmen.
Er habe die Ungerechtigkeit
nicht mehr ertragen, sagt er,
zudem sei sein Aggressionspotenzial
gestiegen.
Der Alltag von Sieglinde Kliemen
ist nicht einfach.
Während die drei Frauenhäuser
im Kanton Bern gesamthaft
über 3 Mio. Fr.
vom Sozialamt erhalten,
muss das Männerhaus
ohne staatliches Geld auskommen.
Mit einem jährlichen Budget
von knapp 110'000 Fr.,
zum grössten Teil durch Gönner
und Stiftungen finanziert,
muss sorgsam gehaushaltet werden.
Ich investiere meine Kraft
lieber darin,
hier die Arbeit für Männer in Not
zu leisten
und über Einzelfallhilfen,
bei Stiftungen und wo auch immer,
die Kosten erstattet zu bekommen,
obwohl der Aufwand
für mich grösser ist.
Das Männer- und Väterhaus
gehört zum Verein Zwüschehalt,
der in Aarau, Luzern und Bern
drei Häuser betreibt.
Der Aufbau
war zeitweise eine Ein-Frau-Show:
Sieben Tage die Woche
für alles und jeden da zu sein.
Ist es manchmal zu viel oder geht es?
- Das geht gut.
Das macht es spannend.
Genau. Und es brennt Licht.
Man darf nicht aufgeben,
so das Motto von Sieglinde Kliemen.
Staatlich wird das Männerhaus
nicht unterstützt,
deshalb fehlt auch
die offizielle Kontrolle -
was wiederum Nahrung
für Vorurteile und Kritik bietet.
Und dass ein Mann ein Opfer ist,
scheint schwerer zu beweisen
und zu akzeptieren zu sein.
Bei den Fällen,
die als Opfer zu mir kommen,
passiert es immer wieder,
dass ich nicht anerkannt werde.
Die Opferberatung sagt, es sei
unklar und könne gegenseitig sein
und da gelte das Opferschutzgesetz
nicht.
Psychische Gewalt nachzuweisen,
ist sowieso besonders schwierig,
wenn man nicht
mit dem Messer im Rücken
oder einem gebrochenen Arm kommt
oder mit einem offensichtlichen
Fall, der nachvollziehbar ist.
Wie bei Sebastian.
Ihm wurde seine kleine Tochter
von der KESB zugesprochen.
Für den Moment
ist die Welt wieder in Ordnung.
Wie geht's?
Ja, allerlei jetzt ...
Man ist endlich wieder
mit dem verbunden,
was einem immer wieder gesagt wurde:
dass man sie nie mehr sehen wird
und alles.
Von daher ist man happy.
Nur Sieglinde sei als einzige
richtige Unterstützung geblieben,
sonst habe Sebastian
sein ganzes Umfeld verloren.
Die Kindesmutter versuche ihn
zu isolieren und,
wo es nur geht,
schlecht zu machen.
Er hat in dieser Zeit -
auch wenn es schwer war -
immer das Ziel vor Augen, für seine
Tochter ein guter Vater zu sein.
Hm.
Es ist ein grosses Happy End.
Aber es ist noch nicht das Ende,
es ist erst happy.
Es ist v.a.
eine superprovisorische Lösung,
der Entscheid der KESB.
Ja. - Da ist momentan
noch gar nichts fix.
Was Sebastian alles durchmachen muss,
passt nicht in einen Film.
Es ist ein schier
endlos scheinender Kampf,
bei dem das männliche Geschlecht
ein Nachteil zu sein scheint.
Wenn das für sie schwer zu verdauen
ist, immer wieder,
und sie verzweifeln lässt
und es wieder ein Rückschlag ist,
kann ich das mit ihnen verarbeiten.
Ich kann sie unterstützen
und ihnen helfen, das anzunehmen
und daraus wieder eine Perspektive
zu entwickeln und zu sagen:
"Diese Tür ist zu, eine andere
geht auf. Wir schauen weiter."
Das kann ich gut,
aber wenn ich selbst
die Ignoranz der Behörden spüre,
ist es manchmal schon schwierig, ja.
Wie im Fall von David.
Er ist am Aufräumen, seine
beiden Kinder sind nicht mehr hier.
Bei einem begleiteten Besuch hat die
Frau die Kinder einfach mitgenommen,
obwohl es anders abgemacht war.
Und das war es dann. Sie hat sie
einfach mitgenommen. Ohne Probleme.
Jetzt sind sie nicht mehr geschützt.
Jetzt muss man schauen,
wie man die Verbindung hält.
Da gehen einem
sehr viele Sachen durch den Kopf.
Man kann nicht einschätzen,
was genau ist.
Wo gehen sie hin? Was machen sie?
Was geschieht mit den Kindern?
Die Väter nehmen die Kinder
nicht zum Spass hierher.
Sie bringen sie hierher,
um sie in Schutz zu bringen,
weil sie sich Sorgen machen.
Werden sie nicht gehört
oder ernst genommen -
und solche Situationen entstehen -
und er merkt,
es hilft ihm niemand ...
Und niemand glaubt es.
Das ist es: Niemand glaubt es!
Niemand glaubt einem.
Verzweiflung, Trauer, Wut.
Drei Gefühle,
mit denen Mann hier leben muss.
Man kann ja auch vernünftig,
getrennt voneinander zusammensitzen
und schauen,
welche Lösungen es gibt,
damit beide da rauskommen.
Fair.
Das braucht Vernunft.
Das braucht einerseits Vernunft.
Andererseits braucht es ein System,
das gerecht hinschaut,
ohne Vorurteile.
Ohne Vorverurteilung
oder Stigmatisierung.
Es gibt sie, die Geschichten,
bei denen die Männer
die vermeintlichen Frauen sind
und gegen die klassischen
Geschlechterrollen ankämpfen müssen.
Wir legen dich ins Bettchen.
Die Dunkelziffer,
wie oft Männer unter Gewalt leiden,
sei wahrscheinlich hoch,
hört man hinter vorgehaltener Hand,
auch bei den entsprechenden Behörden.
Dass hier eine männliche Minderheit
ihre Sicht schildern konnte,
schmälert in keiner Weise das Leid,
das Frauen erfahren.
Trotzdem ist es wohl angezeigt,
die gängigen Klischees zu überprüfen
und Frauen- oder Männerbilder
zu hinterfragen.
* Sanfte Einschlafmusik:
"Guten Abend, gute Nacht" *